[Música]
eu quero fazer mais provocação do que
trazer grandes experiências
a gente vai navegar por um pouco de
história
para contextualizar a entender o que é
essa tal da economia criativa
vou citar alguns exemplos e deixa
algumas sugestões no final
quero deixar vocês impactadas com as
informações que eu posso trazer para a
vida de cada um
a minha vida sempre foi muito construída
através de ações criativas e inovação e
tecnologia todo o meu desenvolvimento
profissional eu sempre tive contato com
criação inovação e tecnologia aliás a
tecnologia é uma coisa da qual não abro
mão sem ela não teria conseguido criar
três filhos e e colocá-los no mundo
fazer fazer os homens profissionais da
tecnologia sempre me ajudou muito nessa
missão em quase que impossível mas pra
falar de cidades criativas eu costumo
usar três exemplos é um bem longe daqui
que ela na inglaterra e dois que são
mais próximos que são do estado de são
paulo
na inglaterra existe uma cidade
lancashire é muito pequena
onde tem um vento constante quase igual
ao nosso ar condicionado é um vento
cortante e que isso faz com que a cidade
não era visitada por conta desse evento
até que um dia um prefeito meio louco e
fez um desafio para os designers dos
artistas dos arquitetos da cidade e
falou assim ah pelo amor de deus a gente
possa resolver esse problema desse
evento com uma solução criativa não sei
qual venham com idéias e possibilidades
pra gente causar algum impacto na cidade
e vieram várias sugestões e dessas
várias sugestões quatro grandes
esculturas fonte foram escolhidas foram
construídas e colocadas em pontos
estratégicos da cidade
hoje a cidade conhecida carinhosamente
como a terra
o vento cantante porque todas as escutas
aproveitam o evento para fazer com que
soy uma música na cidade por conta disso
a cidade passou a receber perto de 35
mil visitantes por mês
a criatividade fez a diferença na cidade
aqui no estado de são paulo a gente tem
duas cidades e uma em embu das artes
onde nada a criatividade provocou
desenvolvimento e provoca até hoje mas
não foi de uma forma muito planejada foi
acontecer do e hoje a cidade é conhecida
por comercializar artesanato e artes e é
isso que move a economia local
já em olímpia é alguns anos atrás há
quase 50 anos atrás se iniciou uma festa
do folclore
essa festa foi ganhando corpo hoje não
mais de 50 anos de comemoração é um
grande evento que acontece sempre no mês
de agosto trazendo manifestações
culturais do país inteiro mas é só no
mês de agosto
e aí a cidade precisa sobreviver os
outros meses como fazer recentemente em
2014 ela ganhou a cidade ganhou o título
de município de interesse por turístico
estância de águas por conta de um grande
empreendimento um parque de águas que
tem na cidade e isso fez com que o
movimento se estabelecer na cidade fosse
criado um grande desenvolvimento
são pequenos exemplos pra gente é
provocar o nosso pensamento acerca do
que a gente pode fazer
a história da economia criativa história
meio recente ela acontece lá em 1994
quando o kit primeiro-ministro na
austrália também tentando provocar
desenvolvimento constrói o primeiro as
primeiras políticas públicas pensadas
para um país com base em arte cultura
o tony blair que não é bobo nem nada viu
que aquela coisa tava funcionando bacana
lá na austrália ele fala vou colocar
isso também no meu plano de governo e
ele coloca em 1997 hoje em inglaterra é
conhecida quando ou como o primeiro pólo
disseminador dessa coisa da economia
criativa aqui no brasil a a economia
criativa ela chega
meio que devagarzinho entre 2010 e 2014
a gente chega a ter uma secretaria de
economia criativa vinculada ao
ministério da cultura onde nasci em
alguns programas e o programa a
secretária hoje já não existem mais dois
milhões de motivos e eu não tenho
certeza se isso foi uma boa saída porque
a economia criativa ficou com uma ideia
meio que errada talvez de que é sinônimo
de cultura cultura economia da cultura é
a mesma coisa não não é a mesma coisa
cultura é uma da palma pequena parte de
toda a economia criativa cultura é
também economia criativa economia
criativa tem outros segmentos como
tecnologia a biomedicina a internet das
coisas desenvolvimento de software
a gente tem vários outros setores
ligados à economia criativa ea gente
desconhece será que você é que atua como
artista como desenvolvedor de software
o engenheiro ambientalista se de repente
você também não está dentro dessa
economia criativa por algum motivo
fazendo parte desse mapeamento que ainda
há gente não tem
a gente sabe que a história da economia
criativa por ser muito recente a gente
não tem muitas informações não têm
muitos dados a gente ainda está
engatinhando nisso e onde estão os
grandes empregos a gente sabe que a
gente não tem muito emprego mais nas
grandes indústrias a gente não tem
cuidado de emprego suficiente para o
número de pessoas que existem no planeta
a a gente tem dificuldade de termos
muitos empregos ea gente também sabe que
a maioria dos empregos
estatisticamente está centrado nas
pequenas usinas médias empresas será que
boa parte dessa economia criativa não
está gerando ou girando nessas pequenas
e médias empresas é temos que parar para
repensar a forma do nosso relacionamento
inclusive de trabalho
a gente não tem as grandes compras
grandes empresas também por serem
grandes estarem perdendo mão de obra
estão se rendendo
andando e colocando produtos e serviços
no mercado com base em experiências mais
do que produtos com excelente qualidade
estão diversificando e personalizando
produtos e serviços isso é uma coisa que
tem acontecido recentemente a indústria
o comércio eo agronegócio tem dados mais
do que suficientes ainda não se sabe
quantos empregados quanto impacta quanto
à sua briga quando exporta o comércio
item porque tem dados e informações
quando os comércios com os negócios têm
um município quanto está empregando
quando demitiu quando avançou
agronegócios então tem todas as
informações ripper detalhadas por sermos
muito novos e setal da economia criativa
a gente não tem dados os poucos dados
que têm a gente ainda não se apropriou
deles a gente não consegue usar o sebrae
recentemente fez um levantamento que tem
2 milhões de empresas nesses segmentos
da economia criativa é se esses dois
milhões e sebrae pequena e média empresa
novamente estão gerando perto de 110
milhões de reais o que equivale a quase
3% do pib brasileiro eu desconfio esses
números acho que deve ser mais mas enfim
são os dados que a gente tem e o pnds
investiu de 1997 a 2000 e 14 13 bilhões
de até 3 bilhões de reais a gente fala 3
bilhões mas o valor grande mas quando
dividido pela quantidade de anos a gente
vai ver que um valor pequenininho que
foi investido
a federação internacional da indústria
fonográfica agora em 2007 acabou de
apresentar um relatório onde aponta que
o crescimento da música no mundo beira
os 8% e no brasil foi um crescimento de
quase 18% mais uma vez um segmento
economicamente criativo tendo um apoio e
de crescimento
para facilitar a vida de todo mundo até
porque a economia criativa é muita coisa
eu costumo definir para ficar mais fácil
que a economia criativa
são todos os segmentos todos os
empreendimentos
que tenham como pó mola propulsora a
criatividade a inovação ea tecnologia e
que possam de alguma forma provocar
desenvolvimento em qualquer localidade
isso é muito grande porque a gente
consegue se enxergar dentro dessa
definição ea gente pode incluir muita
gente até porque a economia criativa
ainda está se desenhando e tendo que
achar os seus próprios caminhos
a unesco já reconhece as cidades
criativas no mundo inteiro e segundo a
unesco é um segmento da economia
criativa tem potencial de empregar de
colocar pessoas no mercado e de
potencializar economicamente localidades
fui eu que inventei unesco que definiu
já temos uma rede de cidades criativas
espalhadas no mundo inteiro entre elas a
intensidade no brasil também e um de
efetivamente está toda a riqueza hoje a
riqueza hoje está centrada e
criatividade e inovação de forma
individual e muitas vezes na maioria das
vezes de forma coletiva sozinho a gente
não vai pra lugar nenhum
mas a riqueza está centrada em
criatividade e inovação
é nesse bozo nesse caldeirão todo que
nasce a rede de economia criativa brasil
para disseminar esse conhecimento
compartilhar essas informações com maior
número de pessoas por possível é por
isso que eu estou aqui hoje para
compartilhar com vocês e falar de
economia criativa para que mais pessoas
possam entender e disseminar essas
informações por onde a gente for minhas
sugestões e as minhas mais que sugestões
provocações para que vocês possam levar
e começar a pensar se estão o que podem
fazer por onde começar
a primeira coisa que a gente precisa
fazer é descobrir na minha localidades
ea gente vai pensar de forma coletiva na
qual localidade onde está
qual é a identidade local com a
identidade da minha rua com a identidade
do meu bairro
qual é a minha identidade se a gente for
presente para piracicaba na qual é a
identidade de piracicaba o que existe em
piracicaba que é exclusivo de piracicaba
e não existe nenhum outro lugar do
planeta terra o rio o rio piracicaba só
existe aqui essa águas ocorre aqui não
corre nenhum outro lugar do mundo ea
identidade da cidade está construída com
base no rio ela foi construída em torno
do rio se fixaram aqui historicamente
por conta da da água que tinha foram se
fixando foram se desenvolvendo
abastecendo agricultura enfim é o rio é
o rio a razão da existência de
piracicaba será que médicos
ambientalistas sociólogos filósofos
ambientalistas professores artistas que
cantam dançam e pintam o rio o médico
que de repente está curando doenças por
conta do rio o engenheiro que está
pensando em soluções de saneamento por
conta do rio
o desenvolvedor de software que está
pensando numa solução ande por conta das
enchentes enfim a gente tem de alguma
forma toda ligação com rio e estamos
pensando em produtos e serviços
criativos por conta dele
eu não acredito que a gente consiga
fazer sozinho eu só acredito que a gente
consegue fazer as coisas se mobilizando
se unindo coletivos grupos pra poder
juntos brigar por melhores qualidades e
implantar ao provocar algum tipo
desenvolvimento algum tipo de mudança é
só juntos que a gente vai avançar
as empresas por sua vez elas podem
colaborar com esse desenvolvimento
investindo e fortalecendo por exemplo
está tap pequenos empreendimentos que
estão inovando de alguma forma com
produtos e serviços é pra para a região
e pra pra cidade
o poder público com políticas públicas
mas de alguma forma a gente como a
sociedade tem que está provocando o
poder público vocação agrícola turismo
a nossa indústria automobilística que
não tem
não estamos formando não temos designers
com foco em hindu na indústria
automobilística já que isso não pode uma
possibilidade de negócio
será que uma vocação do comércio central
de moda não pode fortalecer o
desenvolvimento de novos estilistas
enfim tudo isso está dentro da economia
criativa a internet das coisas é
fundamental porque a internet das coisas
ela pode servir pra melhorar a
mobilidade urbana ela pode servir para
melhorar condições de qualidade de vida
e saúde ela serve nenhum serve na
educação a internet das coisas está
permeando a nossa vida o tempo todo
será que a gente não pode focar os
nossos trabalhos com a internet das
coisas
na finalizando políticas públicas
precisam ser implementadas para que o
desenvolvimento aconteça e não dá pra
pensar políticas públicas sem ter um
tripé é comunidade é poder público e
empresas todos trabalhando juntos para
que a coisa aconteça sem isso nada vai
pra frente
obrigada